in the U.S the troubled First Republic
Bank is being acquired by JP Morgan
Chase Regulators had taken control of
the bank the third major institution in
the U.S to fail in two months First
Republic shares fell last week after it
revealed customers had withdrawn 100
billion dollars in deposits in March
that was the month Silicon Valley Bank
and Signature Bank collapsed causing
fears of a wider Market Fallout
let's join Kristen salumi live for us
now in New York and Christian tell us a
bit more about what led to this takeover
well U.S Regulators stepped in in the
early morning hours and seized First
Republic Bank and then turned around and
immediately sold it to J.P Morgan Chase
I'm standing outside of the headquarters
here in Manhattan New York uh this was
uh after a weekend of intensive
negotiations to try to prevent another
bank failure that would cause panic in
the markets and distrust among investors
the government stepped in did these
negotiations and Chase came to the
rescue First Republic of course had been
teetering on the Brinks of collapse ever
since those other two Banks collapsed in
March the issues for all three of the
banks were similar they relied on
Wealthy deposits and Wealthy depositors
who were not protected by federal
insurance if a bank were to collapse the
issue for them is rising interest rates
they had these loans and Investments
that lost billions of dollars as a
result of rising interest rates and they
just could not keep up so again this uh
quick action on the part of Chase Bank
which they're hoping will prevent other
Banks from going down the same road 30
billion dollars had been invested in
First Republic but that was not enough
to save it so the good news today is
that people who have money and First
Republic Bank will be able to go to
those branches and access their money
those banks are now branches of Chase
Bank
so that bank's been saved Chris symbol
of course the big question is whether
more banks are at risk and what it means
for the broader economy
right absolutely and Jamie dimon the CEO
of Chase took to Twitter today uh saying
that this puts the worst of this crisis
behind us basically that the uh this
aspect of the banking crisis is largely
over and the markets do seem to be
taking it all in stride their overall
trading uh slightly higher than they
were last week mostly in the green some
banking stocks are trading lower but
nothing drastic not the DraStic uh pull
out of the banking sector that some had
feared might happen a bigger question is
what this means for the economy going
forward because uh Rising interest rates
have forced many banks to pull back on
loaning to businesses and to individuals
and so that could have a chilling effect
on the economy overall but for now it
seems that crisis has been averted Okay
Christian slimy in New York thank you